I have some very valuable information on
floaters and how to get rid of floaters
the most important thing you need to
understand about floaters is what are
floaters in the first place okay like
you have these little worm like things
floating in your eyes that really
probably are irritating you some of you
have them and you got used to them so it
doesn't bother you what is a floater for
real is it just some broken collagen
protein that just kind of floating
around and it's basically this you have
this accumulation of this collagen fiber
in a certain form that is damaged from
and I'm going to give you a new word
here it's been glycated what does that
mean it means that it's stuck to a sugar
molecule so when you connect a protein
to a sugar or a sugar to a fat it gets
stuck now that protein becomes
unavailable and it kind of clogs up the
body well that's what these eye floaters
are the official name is advanced
glycation n products just picture um
you're in an ocean and you see this
jellyfish right and it's floating along
and you can kind of see right through it
because it's translucent and this
jellyfish happens to be eating all these
little sugary treats right and all the
sugar is kind of like binding with the
this gel okay in this jellyfish and it's
making these little wormlike
structures which are basically the
connection of that collagen to that suar
so it makes it cloudy in the eye you
have this called vitous gel which is
basically a translucent you can see
through it a protein of collagen and so
when you lose your protective mechanism
which are antioxidants this glycation
starts to occur especially if you're on
a high carb diet now here's the question
is there anything that can get rid of
this okay and the answer is yes there
are many things that you can do or take
that are considered
anti-glycation in other words they
prevent this binding of the sugar to the
protein one reference that I found it's
called the PDR now it's not in the
current versions it's in the older
versions they have a natural remedy for
eye floaters and all three of these
remedies create an
anti-glycation effect so that would be
choline an acetol and methine so you
would take choline in a thousand
milligrams per day that's one gram you
would take a ncol 500 milligrams each
day and then with methionine you would
only need 200 mgram so that is the ratio
that was advised years ago in the
Physician's Desk Reference now I found a
lot of other research on this topic that
you can also add to this mixture one
being lysine which is another amino acid
that's been very very promising in
creating significant Improvement in eye
floaters and I would add one to three
grams depending how bad your floaters
are and this mixture I would recommend
to take an empty stomach because that
way it won't interfere with other
proteins if you then add intermittent
fasting and maybe even some prolong
fasting to this protocol I think it
would greatly speed it up but I will say
that this remedy does take a bit of time
it takes some months for it to work but
with the fasting I think you'll see some
results with in weeks the other advice
I'm going to recommend is to start to
cut down your sugar okay I'm talking
about going on a low carb diet and the
name for that is the ketogenic diet so
you'd want to add that as well because
if you take a look at a diabetic usually
has higher amounts of sugar they have
much greater incidence of having these
floaters than a non-diabetic and when
you do keto you want to do the healthy
version of Keto because of the
antioxidants we want more antioxidants
so vegetables with high vitamin C would
be very helpful also Meats and Seafood
that are loaded with zinc zinc can also
help give you an anti-glycation effect
now because of the censoring and the
suppressing of the algorithms on YouTube
it's becoming more difficult to find my
content and there's a lot of content
that I cannot put on YouTube
unfortunately so to make sure you have
full access of all my information go to
drberg.com And subscribe to my
newsletter by clicking the link Down
Below in the description I will see you
on the other side now since we're
talking about your eyes there's some
very interesting information about eyes
in this video that I think you'll really
enjoy right
here